I think it speaks to the health of
American society that people don't buy
into envy and and class antagonisms the
way the left thinks they do I am Nick
Gillespie with reason TV and we are
talking today with grover norquist's
he's the president of Americans for Tax
Reform and the author most recently of
the new book and the IRS before it ends
us how to restore a low tax high growth
wealthy America Grover thanks for
talking yes in the book you talk about
how in 2014 at all levels of government
government consumed 34% of GDP that's a
high tax by your I mean some people
would want to hire but it's high tax by
you what should that rate be or hat what
how do we know what the right rate is in
1774 before we became a country
Americans were paying 1 to 2 percent of
their income in taxes the British in
London were paying 20% in order to
oppress us we were paying 1 to 2 percent
I want to go closer to one to two away
from 34 there's no magic number it's
lower if it's but is it always less or
I'm in and in a low tax kind of world is
it that taxes always have to be getting
cut to keep growth going or is it that
you can hit a steady state where the
government just isn't that big a deal
if we can bring spending down and tax
rates down it'll be less destructive of
economic growth the most important thing
we can do is rein in spending reform
government entitlements so that they
cost less over time and the taxes can
come down they look we need a national
defense and some courts and and so on
beyond that government becomes cowboy
poetry readings absolutely yeah and that
other than that beyond that it becomes
destructive of urine liberty rather than
conducive when you say n the IRS both in
the title of book and throughout I mean
you literally mean getting rid of the
Internal Revenue Service as it exists
what what is it about that agency that
is you know that did that is other than
kind of populist anger that to be put in
the title it there's an intrusive miss
there's a power
it is it allows the government to get
big I think it allowed our participation
in World War one on a massive scale sort
of defending our coastlines or our
shipping we had this button you could
turn Oh massive amounts of cash and
Wilson was able to jump into a war that
otherwise you'd have to thought about
the costs and how you'd raise the money
and so on so it empowers the government
like a switch to go way up it could come
down again but it just tends to go it's
a ratchet it's - it gives the government
too much power and too much control over
our lives and we don't have to have it
for most of our country's history we
didn't have an income tax in our 50
states 9 don't have an income tax I
think in the next 15 years it'll be 25
that don't have income taxes you're
seeing a number of states looking to
follow Kansas's model of ratcheting the
income tax personal income tax down yeah
talks with bit about chances because
this has been and and of course with
States I mean most of them only put in
income taxes in between the late 60s and
70s we Kansas generally people say like
you got to be kidding me Norquist the
Kansas is up the you know it's up the
river without a paddle in terms of
revenues have plummeted and everything's
going to hell in a handbasket what
you're rejoinder to that Kansas is the
future Kansas is the model they had 50
years of bipartisan overspending 50
years of Lincoln Republicans the people
who are Republicans because they were
Kansas was with the north during the
Civil War and they haven't thought about
it since they're not Reagan so this is
the Bob Dole's
of the world yeah they're Republicans
because they're born north of the
mason-dixon line . it became a Reagan
Republican House Senate and governorship
only with Brownback's governorship he
turned around and began passed a law
that phases out the income tax over time
as revenue comes in from economic growth
more than 2% you ratchet down the income
tax they were ratcheted up only ratchet
it down but what about I mean they are
cutting a lot of spending and are not it
were not as much as they need to
obviously all the spending interests
consider themselves
what is there anything that a place like
Kansas it's a big state it has no really
major city in a Kansas City as a
Missouri which it has the biggest city
of 300,000 people you know is there
anything that Kansas can do to actually
make people want to move there it's also
depopulated well two things the first
thing you do is not make people leave
you actually have seen people move into
Kansas across the border from Missouri
because they specifically cut taxes on
small business pastors small businesses
so for a whole bunch of that border
people move a couple of blocks in
because it's a big deal Missouri's taxes
are way too high well let's talk about
the kind of federal plans that you talk
then you run through various possible
reforms the Fair Tax the flat tax on
what you call the Golden Triangle of tax
reform the fair tax define it and then
you're critical of it although you like
the the basic idea what's what's up with
the fair tax the fair tax says let's get
rid of the income tax completely and
unless you do that with a constitutional
amendment the Fair Tax is dangerous
because because it becomes an add-on and
it's essentially a national sales tax
yes
what it does it taxes consumed income
one time at one rate now you can also do
that through a flat tax you just exempt
savings and investment so both of those
get you the right base consumed income
taxed one time at one rate why one rate
means it's very difficult to increase
I'm originally from Massachusetts prior
to emigrate in the United States and we
have a flat rate income tax in
Massachusetts by Constitution tough to
race Illinois has a flat rate income tax
tough to raise because you have to look
everybody in the state in the eye and
say I've got a great idea
and you're all paying for it if you
divide it with a graduation progressive
income tax you can bug people one at a
time okay so the Fair Tax is good
because it's flat rate it's simple and
in taxes income once which is a big deal
the idea that dollars shouldn't
constantly being taxed again and again
until they're shredded but what's wrong
with the Fair Tax
well there's strategic questions if you
switched over tomorrow it wouldn't
matter whether you had a flat tax or a
fair tax to a 20 year old but to a 65
year old who has paid taxes on their
income all their life now
is going to live off their savings a
fair tax taxes all their savers so and
since older people tend to vote more
frequently than younger people that's a
real problem so then let's go to the
flat tax yeah you know talk through your
preferred flat tax plan well you want to
go where you exempt all savings and
investments you have a 401 K that's
infinitely expandable you pay taxes on
consumed income a flat rate tax and you
want to take that rate as low as you
possibly can you wrestle with spending
in order to reduce the rate further and
further
what of any of the flat tax plans that
have been brooded about you know is one
of them better than the other the
rubbish go Forbes plan or or you're not
that they're all in the right direction
yeah I want to get that way and again
the idea is that income is taxed our
dollar is taxed once it's flat and it's
universal correctly and and what you
don't if the government has to come in
and tax the same dollar over and over
again they have to follow your bank
account your investments what's in your
basement it's to less intrusive if they
watch you once those kinds of privacy
concerns work with a certain type of
conservative they work with libertarians
do they work to convince other you know
say liberals or political agnostics you
know who I mean does work are they just
kind of like hey where's your tinfoil
hat I'm not saying no it's a it's a with
anyone who pays income taxes and knows
the level of detail what you have to get
into if you've ever done an estate when
you have to know everything how much
gold is in somebody's teeth when they
pass away I mean you have to know every
all their assets there's no reason for
the government to be that intrusive
bothers people
well let's talk about you know what what
is the you know what's the triangle of
reform that you're interested in kind of
procedure this is sort of what Reagan
did you take the rates down but you go
to full expensing so instead of long
depreciation schedules you go to full
expense it what does that do thousand
pages out of the tax code you don't have
to decide this computer is good for
three years or four years or five years
if you spend a dollar you expense it for
equipment
equipment tremendous simplification
tremendously reduces the cost of capital
investment rates as low as you can
25 to 20 percent at the first cut and
then last territoriality so the
government only steals money that you
aren't here in the United States you
earn it in France the French will steal
some of it you can bring what they don't
steal back with you and this is both for
personal income but especially business
income talk a little bit about how the
corporate income tax I mean we've had a
bunch of scenarios where you Burger King
moves to Canada by stims for Tim Hortons
moves to Canada to avoid a tax by talk
about territoriality look territoriality
is what the way most countries operate
we have the universal tax the United
States government thinks that should be
able to tax money you makin in Germany
that reduces competition and has allowed
our rates to remain high when others
have reduced them but we want to have is
a competition and it keeps people from
bringing money back to the connector
right I mean this is the corporate
there's a reason why Apple is you know
warehousing servers in Ireland and
keeping the money there there's two
trillion dollars worth of American
corporate assets overseas that could
come back tomorrow if we allowed people
olly olly and free to bring the money
back without taxing it that's an
important first step
I like the competitive part of that
where each country competes to provide
the best government at the lowest cost
and to keep rates down you lose that
with the university and alternatively
it's true of states in the United States
right California could say hey we're
gonna have high taxes and MyServices
Texas low states low service and people
can sort they do and for those of us who
think smaller government lower taxes is
a better idea guess what most people are
weathers people are moving from high tax
states to low tax states the one who
want to stay in Vermont they can stay in
Vermont but what we are seeing is more
and more states beginning the process of
following Kansas to go to a zero income
tax and we're gonna go from nine I think
up to 20 or 25 the next 15 years that's
part of educating people that you don't
necessarily
a national income tax as more and more
states have no state income tax Marco
Rubio Senator Marco Rubio Florida
Senator Mike Lee of Utah recently came
out with a tax plan that gets it it
speaks to a lot of the concerns you're
talking about it's simplified it creates
two rates for personal income it changes
some depreciation stuff on business
what's your general take on the the
Rubio Lee plan the originally we're
going to focus more on just raising the
deduction or credit per child which is
good for families but doesn't help you
on economic growth they and it actually
blows a hole in the budget because they
don't take expensive in terms of
expensive to the government right but
they added to that zeroing out the
capital gains tax almost reducing taxes
all taxes on savings and investment so
it's actually turbocharged on a gross
side so between the two it's not a bad
marriage of two ideas so well but I mean
from a kind of fair tax flat tax point
of view should we be getting rid of
deductions like or you know deductions
for children deductions for particular
types of economic activity you know why
should the government be saying you know
it's okay that you spend money on
medicine or an education as opposed to
cars or whatever one would prefer to
face that sort of stuff out and I think
on that you have to grow away from those
things if you threaten them somebody and
you said can do three good things for
you and and do this other thing that
threatens you people are paralyzed by
the one that threatens you and they
don't see the three helpful pieces so
I'm much more into economic growth to
move away from some of those challenges
what is the you know you mentioned
zeroing out capital gains and obviously
this is something Bill Clinton didn't
actually do that but he dramatically
reduced or capital gains rates were
reduced heavily yeah what is it how do
you do how do you explain that or
justify that or get persuade people who
are liberal or who think you know what
that capital gains should be taxed as
regular income or even more because
they're ill-gotten what what's the
argument to get them to see it
differently part of it is you're taxing
the same dollar a second time it's like
the argument against the death
interestingly the death tax hits very
few people maybe less than 1% now that
it's been pruned back and yet 70 percent
of the American people today and for the
last 30 years
have supported getting rid of the death
tax I think it speaks to the health of
American society that people don't buy
into envy and and class antagonisms the
way the left thinks they do if we could
learn to talk about capital gains the
way we do talk about the death tax and
say look you're taxing the same dollar a
second or a third time and this is all
savings death taxes all savings capital
gains is all savings you don't want to
take savings out of the economy that's
what creates jobs and investment let's
talk about kind of federal taxes as a
percentage of GDP total federal taxes
business individual all all receipts for
the federal government in 2014 according
to the tax policy came to seventeen
point five percent of GDP that is as a
percentage that is lower a lower rate
than the last three years of the budget
of the Reagan budget ears isn't
seventeen point five percent and you
know what are we complaining about then
spending too much okay so yeah and let's
talk about spending because you know
roaming around here and you mentioned
entitlement reform you know which is
really driving spending more than any
single other factor but between 2009 and
2013 the feds borrowed thirty three
cents of every dollar they spent it's
clear you know and revenue was going
down it didn't stop them from spending
Reagan borrowed a hell of a lot of money
you know it so isn't this idea that if
we drive tax rates down
we will curtail spending is just clearly
wrong from the historical record and do
we need to be worrying less about taxes
and more focused on spending
no yes no okay if you cut taxes it does
not necessarily discipline spending
because the spenders have no objections
to deficit spending they will keep
spending and think if they can do it
second if you raise taxes they will
increase spending as much as you raise
the taxes and more historically when you
raise taxes they spend it plus in
anticipation but under Bill Clinton
because Bill Clinton did raise taxes
early in his career and then in terms of
overall revenue as a percentage of GDP
they were collecting like 20 percent of
the of the economy at the end of his
term but spending actually flattened or
came down a little bit
Republican House and Senate 94 that's
what flip the growth the job creation
the stock market was flat for the two
years when he raised taxes as soon as
the Republicans what I am saying that I
mean isn't there an argument that if
people I mean if you raise taxes in
order to pay for spending people
recognize that oh my gosh government
actually cost something if you can buy
like between 2009 and 2013 if you can
buy a dollars worth of government
spending and you're only paying 67 cents
you're kind of stupid not to say yeah
yeah you know what give me more give me
more
that would work except there's the 300
million people but each individual has
not got the same some people are raising
taxes not getting anything at all for it
so it's not quite it's not some
collective decision that we made when
Reagan got elected he said the
Republican Party's the party of tax cuts
when which it wasn't before it's party
deficits fighting deficits which could
mean tax increases like Goldwater wrote
Gingrich got elected and said we're the
governing majority in this country if we
just act properly and and be true to
ourselves oh really we can't be the
majority you know we're not we don't
have to sort of cheat our way into power
because nobody agrees with us people do
agree with us and then the third change
in the Republican Party thinking was the
Tea Party spending spend
spending they took earmarks which had
been seen for 50 years as a sign of
virility in a congressman or senator I
have have stolen money from other
districts and I bring it back and give
it to somebody who lives near you
I brought a brontosaurus we all eat
tonight this was considered something
that was quite heroic that someone did
people would put it in their obituaries
about how they brought money back to
their district now it's like farting at
the dinner table
it's like shoplifting you don't talk
about it all right well we will leave it
there and the new book by grover
norquist's of americans for tax reform
is end the IRS before it ends us how to
restore a low tax high growth wealthy
America I look forward to living in that
America someday Thank You Grover give us
a couple weeks thanks so much for reason
TV I'm Nick Gillespie